- Let's not be so
short-term on everything.
Just, you know, just following my heart.
You got to change as a
person, you got to get better.
You know I want to grow, I
want to continue to grow.
Man, you know who inspired me, man,
I was just inspired by really both coasts.
We do this for the people that's in line
when we pull up to the venues.
When I do interviews, 20 in a day,
I like to sit with (beep)
that makes sense with me.
You got to just put the
right teams together now
and you could be on a
whole nother ball game.
Man, the way I'm feeling right now,
it ain't even about the numbers no more.
You doon't be content,
you don't be content.
- He's an American
rapper and entrepreneur.
In 2009 he founded the record
label, Maybach Music Group.
He was the first artist signed
to Diddy's management company.
He's Rick Ross and here are
his top 10 rules for success.
- You know, I just feel
everybody's situation is unique,
I feel everybody's situation is different,
but most definitely you
got to think of tomorrow,
and not just today, so
the decisions you make
you should most definitely
consider, you know, long-term
and I think that's the
difference, you know,
let's not be so short-term
on everything, now, now, now,
let's kind of, let's be patient
on a lot of different things
and most definitely
investing is one of them.
- How do you choose what
businesses you get involved in?
- You know really just, just
following my heart, really,
everything that I've really
done up to this point
was something that I really
had love or passion for.
- Yeah.
- Because if it's lifestyle I
feel like we going to win at it,
you know what I mean, if it's fashion,
if it's something to deal with,
because you know, we give a lot of game.
We leaders when it come
to that type of stuff.
- Yeah, you're not just
throwing your name,
attaching your name to--
- Nah, nah, nah, nah.
- So much has happened between
your first album and now.
Talk to me about have you
changed as a person, like,
your friends around changed--
- You got to change.
You got to change as a
person, you got to get better.
You know, times change, you
know, your position change,
your rank change, your power
change, you influence change.
And all these things,
hopefully you can use them in a
positive way, where you and
your team could benefit from.
- Do you feel like being
financially smart is one of
the reasons why you'll
basically be rich forever,
why you're a hood
billionaire, so to speak?
- I most definitely think
that's real important, just,
it all leads back to your
lifestyle, you know, longevity
and just taking advantage
of the situations
and opportunities you have and
I feel just through the past
and so many different eras
and times we've seen people
that was just so successful,
or appeared successful
and ended up in different
situations so most definitely,
I want to grow, I want
to continue to grow.
- Who inspired you coming up in the game?
- Man, you know who inspired me, man,
I was just inspired by really both coasts.
I just remember when the NWA wave hit,
I was still in elementary
school and the storytelling that
Ice Cube and the crew
over there was doing,
and then I think it was the
fashion and the style of the
East Coast when I saw them
dookie ropes and I saw them
500 SCL Diesel Convertible
Mercedes and them
Convertible IROCs, of course
these youngsters don't know
what they is 'cause I was a
youngster then and I was like
yo, man, we got to get on our
hustle, we got to turn up.
You know, when you make music
you got to please yourself.
That's the only way you're going
to continue to drive yourself
for doing this for so long
and if you don't agree or like
the type of records that's
being made, there's other stores
you can walk in, you know what I'm saying?
We do this for the people
that's in line when we pull up
to the venues, we do this for
the fans that we love that was
standing in line last night
to get their Self Made 3
CD covers made, and those are
the people who we talking to,
those are the ones we making music for.
I'm going to keep it real, when
I do interviews, 20 in a day,
I like to sit with (beep)
that makes sense with me,
you understand, and a lot
of times the games don't,
but the hustle always do,
that's why when you see me
I got a quarter million
piece on 'cause I used to eat
mayonnaise sandwiches when we came up,
and we don't have time to play games.
Niggas die where I'm from,
SWATs down on the roof,
nigga, and shoot two two threes.
I don't know how to play with niggas,
I don't know how to ask and
answer frivolous questions,
but I respect you being a hustler,
'cause you sitting here,
but you got to hustle,
I'm just telling you, and
the brand got to hustle.
- In the scheme of like
everybody, from like Jay and Kanye
down to like a newcomer,
where do you see yourself?
- Um--
- 'Cause you the boss, right?
- Most definitely.
- [Angie] But do you
feel like you've peaked,
do you feel like you're there?
- Nah, most definitely
not, I mean, I feel like
the biggest moves that's
happening in our generation
are things that we just
created in the last few years.
I mean, from apps and
Instagram, Twitter, so on
and so forth, these are billion
dollar plays that's coming
together in two, three
years, short period of time,
so you got to look at things
differently from when you
approach them maybe
from, to now, you know,
you got to just put the
right teams together now
and you could be on a
whole nother ball game
and once you put yourself in a
position where you can afford
to finance some of these ideas
and try some of these things,
it's a good chance if you--
- [Angie] But do you put
yourself up there with like,
let's say somebody like Puff or Jay?
- And as far as my peers,
you know, I absorb game.
Jay brought me to New York and
signed me to Def Jam Records.
Puff was one of the first dudes
to show me what a real bag
of money looked like, here, you
know what I'm talking about?
- [Angie] He showed you a bag.
- Oh yeah, the big homie
done gave me a bag.
That's g-talk, shout out to
Puff Daddy, Bad Boy, yeah,
you already know, Ciroc
boys forever, ya dig?
- [Angie] But do you
aspire to be on their neck,
or do you think you're
on their neck already?
- I'm in the back of they mind.
- Can you tell me a number,
where are we at with
the Wing Stops right
now, how many Wing Stops
does Rick Ross has his hands in?
- Man the way I'm feeling
right now, it ain't even about
the numbers no more, man,
it's just about the plays
we executing and just us,
whatever it is we got,
we just doing the best with what we doing
and we keep growing and
that's what's happening,
so I'm happy to see the team
from the managers, the team,
all the new people that's
bringing that new energy,
that's what's making this boss
wings thing grow, you know.
- That feeling got to be
priceless, you got kids coming in
wanting to take these pictures
with you, see you in person,
what's this all like
for you, just overall?
- I think at the end of
the day, I also feel good
just showing them that
other side of fast money
or music money, it's called
investing in what you love.
This is something that
I love, so this is what
we invested in and we
build it around the family
and a lot of times that's what dudes do.
They get the money bag and
then go build it with everybody
but the family, you know it take time,
but I think that's how
you supposed to do that.
- [Interviewer] When can you
consider it's enough hustling?
And I know, a hustler,
is never enough hustling,
can never get enough, but when
are you going to sit there
and say alright, I'm done, I'm cool,
I'm content with where I'm at right now--
- You don't be content,
you don't be content.
You don't be content, you understand,
you can never be content.
This place is, it ain't content,
it ain't built to be
content, there's a difference
when you rich and you
supposed to be rich, and
when you rich and you know
you ain't supposed to be rich.
I'm rich and I know I
ain't supposed to be rich.
I like my money physically in bags,
not what the bank say.
I like my (beep) where I can see it,
I like to weigh my (beep).
Every 88 pounds you better
know what that mean,
just know that, you'll never
retire, you'll never get tired.
Thank you so much for watching!
I made this video because
Izag Illa, I really hope I
pronounced that somewhat
closely to the actual
pronunciation, asked me
to, so if there's a famous
entrepreneur that you
want me to profile next,
leave it in the comments below
and I'll see what I can do.
I'd also love to know which
of Rick Ross's top 10 rules
meant the most to you, had the
biggest impact, leave it in
the comments, I'll join the discussion.
Thank you so much for watching,
continue to believe,
and I'll see you soon.